salve sono vincenzo pugliese
diciamo sono abituato
sono solito varie volte su questo palco
ma da musicista e quindi ho suonato
parecchi parecchi concerti non sono
molto abituato a parlare davanti a un
pubblico così grande e comunque sono
visto che si parla di coraggio mi sono
fatto coraggio sulla benzina
io ho cominciato a fare musica
avevo 8 anni
poi i miei genitori mi hanno detto che a
tre anni in un negozio di giocattoli
michelle mi chiesero di scegliere un
solo giocattolo
la coincidenza voluto insomma che scelse
questa tromba queste trombette di
plastica di l'ipo io ho chiesto insomma
i miei genitori di intraprendere la vita
la vita della musica e quindi insomma
otto anni ho cominciato a suonare
frequentati conservatorio
a monopoly bari diciamo
ho avuto una bella carriera artistica
musicalmente parlando frequentando varie
vari festival e varie varie esibizioni
insomma quasi tutto il mondo nel 2004
ritorno da un da un concetto che avevo
fatto con il mio gruppo con il mio
gruppo
ho subito un incidente stradale per
colpa di un pirata della strada come
accennava prima sulla signorina i
dottori mi dissero non a me ma ai miei
genitori che sarei rimasto insomma
allettato per tutta la vita come un
vegetale questo mio padre mi mi raccontò
disse con molta calma questa cosa della
dei dottori e odyssey va bene ok
l'importante che mi portate un computer
e che possono scrivere musica e così fu
fatto dopo due mesi mi portano un
computer con dei comandi vocali e
cominciai a scrivere a scrivere musica
però non mi bastava non guasta perché
comunque volevo volevo ritornare sul mio
strumento solo a suonare la tromba so
che non posso suonarla più alla tromba
con le dita perché non da tetraplegiche
non nuovo più le dita però diciamo con
una serie di amici
con la mia testardaggine siamo arrivati
ad arrivare a farmi costruire una una
tromba costruita sulla diciamo sulla mia
mobilità che è solamente il braccio
l'avambraccio sinistro quindi con questo
movimento io sono una tromba slide tipo
il trombone e con questo movimento
insomma riesco comunque a poter suonare
come prima
da questa tromba c'è stata un'evoluzione
perché ancora ancora una volta non mi
bastava questa tromba perché voglio
ritornare voglio ritornare voglio
ritornare a suonare la tromba pistoni
con la tromba che diciamo nel 2004 mi ha
lasciata dopo l'incidente quando una
serie a
con con degli amici abbiamo abbiamo
fondato un'associazione che si chiama
accor diabili all'intento di costruire
strumenti musicali a disabili che hanno
avuto subito un incidente come me o
comunque disabili che vogliono
intraprendere lo studio della musica con
uno strumento noi studiamo praticamente
uno strumento da costruire direttamente
sulle sue mobilità quindi uno commuovere
il braccio destro come il braccio
sinistro non muove le dita non muove le
gambe
noi studiamo e li diamo la possibilità
di riscattarsi nella propria vita
è quindi in
avere ancora un interazione nella
società e la musica davvero fa tanto io
quando ho fatto l'incidente mi piace
paragonarla così come una partita dove
una partita e diciamo alla finale persa
nel 2004 adesso sto tentando con ho
chiesto la rivincita in questa seconda
vita insomma voglio voglio vincerlo
eccola la mia esperienza diciamo di
musicista con l'associazione accordi
abili vogliamo dare agli altri magari
disabili motori come me
il coraggio insomma di andare avanti il
coraggio di dire che esistiamo
il coraggio di dire viviamo grazie